Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
Part 1 we are getting really close to
the release of fantastic beasts and
where to find them I'm getting really
excited about that I'm having a great
time talking about the Harry Potter
movies with you guys let's get started
now ever since this book was split into
two parts movie studios everywhere we're
like oh oh oh yes that's what I need to
do movie studios everywhere became
Andy's imitation of mr. Potato Head in
the beginning of Toy Story because this
film and its sequel were critically and
financially successful and so everyone
was like oh let's just make Hunger Games
part 1 and 2 let's make the Hobbit three
movies let's do that ascendant Allegiant
bullshit and just oh now it's a TV movie
that's well I didn't really work out
after Deathly Hollows was split into two
part Studios just saw a financial
strategy they didn't understand that
artistically this was a good choice
because this book deserves to be two
movies so let's get this out of the way
a lot of people were wondering what
house I belong to and if I ever took the
Pottermore quiz while I took the
Pottermore quiz and it turns out I
belong to Slytherin
so I'm owning that shit something about
Part one that always gets to me and on
the first time I viewed it especially is
that you know a cliffhanger is coming
whenever you see a movie called part one
you almost expect disappointment he just
kind of go in knowing you're not going
to be fully emotionally fulfilled this
movie opens very fast-paced there's a
very creepy
introduction to Voldemort and all of his
forces and we get a very cool motorcycle
scene where everyone disguises
themselves as Harry Potter and that made
for some incredibly entertaining moments
he'll look away immediacy and also some
very sad moments because Hedwig moment
of silence / Hedwig I also really love
the sequence where they disguise
themselves as people who work for the
Ministry of Magic and they infiltrate
that place and Ron gets a little too
into his disguise
Oh what does it do oh whoops all alone
downstairs you don't have a so as I said
they're looking for the Horcruxes these
things that can destroy Voldemort if
they collect all of them and this film
is more solemn than the others because
our three main heroes go on a very
private journey alone to find these
things and separating them from everyone
else makes the finality of this movie
really hit home because you feel like
well where else are these people going
to go everything is really falling to
shit at this point and having them all
out alone by themselves without any
support from anyone and as they find
these items and these items sometimes
take a toll on them emotionally as
wearing some of them make them change
kind of like a little movie called
Fellowship of the Ring you know I've got
to be the first person alive to make
that comparison but as they're in the
woods and one of these Horcruxes does
take a toll on them emotionally Ron gets
very jealous him and Harry have this big
argument and Hermione she's kind of
sitting there like boys and this leads
to a separating of our three friends
that were so used to seeing together
which makes it even more sad and lonely
and you really do feel like they don't
have anyone this does lead though to one
of my favorite scenes in the movie which
wasn't in the book actually and that's
Harry and Hermione dancing there's
something really sweet about it it's
almost like their last fleeting moment
of happiness and they're just back to
like well life sucks when Harry returns
to where he was born and visits the
gravestone I mean my god that seemed
really got me that was a really touching
moment and the way it's filmed the
cinematography the dark lighting it's
all really beautiful and that's
something that I still am totally blown
away by when it comes to these Harry
Potter movies because usually in a film
series at this point when you get to
this many installments you have fatigue
you're like I get it Harry Potter he has
a wand and does spells and shit but not
with these movies they're all good like
they all build upon each other and very
interesting and fun ways and they keep
the characters fresh and interesting and
the filmmakers never seem to sleep
through anything everyone's always on
their a-game later in the movie when
Harry's in trouble Ron shows up very
rapidly and saves him he has this
word and everything and they destroy
some of the Horcruxes with it because
the sword can do this which is great but
Ron's appearance was just sort of like
oh shit like where's Ron here's Ron
there he is
yay how's thick wise God it just
happened and now we get kind of an
exposition he's seen where we learn
about three brothers and the deathly
hallows and what they are the Elder Wand
the resurrection stone and the cloak of
invisibility now these three things form
the Deathly Hallows yay and this leads
to a magnificent chase seen through the
woods of this forest I love the way
David gates shot the sequence it's so so
breathtaking after they're captured
though we get some suspense about what's
going to happen to them until they're
saved by the one and only Dobby who
fucking dies you're just kind of sitting
there like a I knew this was coming I
can do that
mmm I can do it I'm a man man men don't
cry sometimes men cry though and we get
a big cliffhanger as I said with
Voldemort taking the elder one out of
Dumbledore's dead fingers and just
holding it up to the sky and then you
have to wait for part two guys no
seriousness despite taking a book and
splitting it into two parts and what
that sometimes can do cinematically for
your experience going to the movies
Deathly Hallows Part 1 is a very fun
movie a very enjoyable film one that is
shot beautifully very well acted with a
lot of good emotion and a lot of really
fun scenes is it as action-packed as
other Harry Potter's no but these
characters the direction the way
everything is helmed in this film and
the care that is still being given to
these movies in this many installments
later that makes Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Part 1 a very good film
and I'm going to give it a B+ well guys
we've gotten this far we got one more to
go before fantastic beasts I'm excited
to talk about Harry Potter and Deathly
Hallows part-2
you guys are the best thank you so much
as always for watching if you haven't
seen my other Harry Potter reviews
they're all on my channel in a playlist
thank you once again and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you